here we are with another list
of awesome monsters and this is a
continuation of another video
we did previously of the 20 biggest
american movie monsters but we might not
have included your favorite ones
and so here's another list and this one
is the top 10
more biggest american movie monsters
let's keep this intro short again
and just dive into the rankings but
before that please subscribe to be a
part of our family
and now let's look at monsters
number 10 the queen harvester the
smallest on this list is the queen
harvester from the second independence
day movie
resurgence and she has the hive mind and
the queen of the harvester
aliens you know the ones that were that
attacked earth and got their butts
kicked by ian malcolm and will smith
well the harvester queen came back in
resurgence and she is a very large alien
roughly 216 feet tall in her biosuit
but like her smaller soldiers without
her shield she is vulnerable
and also vulnerable outside her ship and
also she has large tentacles on her back
which are also her weak spot number nine
the bewildered beast coming from the
second how to train your dragon movie
this titan dragon is also called
a leviathan and is a sea dragon which
does not spew up fire but
instead breeds out ice and frost being
one of the largest dragons known to
vikings bewildered bees possess
unmatched strength and power they can
crush massive war contraptions and ships
without even
blinking and plow through mountainsides
as if they were paper walls
they are slow on land since they are
520 feet long and extremely heavy but
they are very agile underwater
number eight stone giants so from the
hobbit we have the giants of the misty
mountains and these
are seen fighting each other in the
movie these stone giants are ancient
monsters of middle-earth
and neutral in a way towards the
dealings of elves men and orcs
the origins of these giants are unknown
as is when exactly they first appeared
in middle-earth however it seems that
they entered history of the peoples of
middle earth in the third age
they look to be over 500 feet tall while
battling each other in the mountains
number 7 the sando aqua monster so in
the previous video we showcased two
gigantic creatures of star wars and now
we bring yet another one
from that universe and this is the apex
predator of the planet naboo
this is the sando aqua monster although
they could grow up to 650 feet long
they were rarely seen and thanks to
their sharp teeth they were capable of
biting through the strong armor of even
giant beasts like the
opc killers and their lifespans
typically reached 100 years
but there was one that lived up to
almost a thousand
number 6 characters coming from the
movie percy jackson the sea of monsters
this creature is a gigantic ocean
dwelling deity that swallows
ships and everything that floats just
with its big mouth
and inside its stomach is a collection
of lost vessels and unlucky travelers
characters was once a beautiful giantess
the daughter of poseidon and gaia
she takes the form of a huge mouth that
swallows great amounts of water and
debris three times a day
creating massive whirlpools and her
overall size would have been at least a
thousand feet
number five the sand worm also known as
the shy hullet
this creature is a staple of the dude
movies and television series
the sandworm is the largest creature of
the planet arrakis and is the source of
the movie's most
valued resource the spice melange they
live in the vast deserts and sand dunes
that stretch all over the
planet the surface of the planet my n1
standard sand worms could grow to an
enormous size
and a certain dr yu from the movie cited
that specimens up to 1
500 feet were spotted by observers in
the deep deserts
number 4 the korathan the dc extended
universe brings a gigantic monster in
the movie aquaman and of course since
the flick is about an underwater kingdom
there would be giant monsters included
and the biggest by far is the keratin
the korathan is a colossal sentient
ancient sea creature
and one of the most powerful beings on
earth she has guarded the trident of
adeline
in hidden sea for millennia and later
assists aquaman
in his quest to prevent war between the
surface world and the sea
she is stated to be over 2 miles long or
10
500 feet number 3 the celestials well we
just did dc
now we come to the marvel cinematic
universe we have seen quite a number of
these celestial beings
in fact with s on the searcher and
nowhere appearing in guardians of the
galaxy vol 1 and ego the living planet
in volume 2
the one known as issa on the searcher
was maybe 2 000 feet tall
and destroyed a planet using the power
stone nowhere who only appeared as a
severed head
had an entire mining colony inside him
and ego was the size of earth's moon and
it took him millions of years to grow to
that size so maybe he was around three
thousand kilometers
number two unicron the very first
incarnation of this god of the
transformers was seen
in transformers the last night but not
fully as
it was just horns that were visible
since the entire planet earth was
unicron itself
therefore he was at least 12 800
kilometers across
unicron is an ancient cybertron deity
who was born
at the dawn of the universe hundreds of
millennia ago earth had formed around
the inner body of unicron
and in the last night quintessa
attempted to kill unicron
but instead caused him to slowly awaken
from his slumber and his horns rising
from the planet's core
and number one galactus and the number
one spot in this list goes to the main
antagonist of the movie fantastic for
the rise of the silver surfer
and this one is none other than galactus
himself appearing
not in his humanoid form but as a
space-faring planet-consuming cloud
galactus was a cosmic entity born within
the universe itself
maybe even before the universe and he
preserves the balance of life by eating
planets and therefore controlling the
population
had thanos galactus in his cloud form
was bigger than even
saturn as seen in the movie which means
he would have been at least a hundred
thousand kilometers in size
and so with that we come to the end of
the video do like for support subscribe
to be a part of our minecube family
and also smash that bell button for
regular updates on new monster videos
right here on this channel till the next
one
take care fam